foreign
good afternoon everyone thank you for
taking the time to come today this is
December's meeting of the external
overview scrutiny committee and my name
is Joe Manley and I'm the chair but we
will go around and introduce our first
shortly if that's all right
um just a bit of housekeeping if there
is a fire
he's been made by accident there's one
over there and one over there
I'm not expecting fire
never doing
um
apologies Karen please yeah
chairman of apology from Kenton Baker
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay such a long time we'll just go
through the minutes of the last meeting
I'll take the Page by Page
um I'll use the bottom page number
um which starts page three
page four
page five
age six
page seven
page eight
nine
and h10 that was a very long meeting
I'm sure
throughout the two hour meeting
sorry and a second uh
all in favor
and against
and two abstentions
nobody thank you
uh I don't have three public
participation we're gonna have any
public
um
the action is
[Music]
and okay with action but it's not much
over there
um we've got the sack less water that's
all going
um hopefully we'll receive updates
through there and as things change and
things happen
um
and then we have received something on
Dentistry I don't know if anybody ever
saw it I could ask how to speculated it
was a bit brief but it was something and
it was kind of guaranteeing Dentistry
care for
children in care
obviously there are lots of other
children I have email we can't see a
counselor Helia
um not very long ago admittedly so we'll
just give a chance to reply RMA and once
I receive reply I hope all it's carrying
to distribute and America and release of
the next meeting that we need to or wish
to discuss that further and that's it on
the action plan
thanks a lot it wasn't on the action
list but I don't remember that I'm using
dad said that she would um
contact me about
um hmos uh do you remember she said
anyway she did yeah
um whether they're going to speak
at the end or not so I have had that
yeah
thank you
thank you councilman
the first number four
on to number five Declaration of
Interest members will be interested with
both the identified
the names of their interests is
considered
agreements in part one and part two
we've only got married
with the commission of the chair I
didn't come in
yes
Christmas has become
okay and now I'd like to take this
opportunity to welcome the Burton art
gallery and thank you for taking the
time to come and see us the family we
look forward to your presentation
[Music]
um my name is Joe Manley I'm the chair
of this and I'm from the north Little
Pennington locally in Plattsburgh
Steve Harding Heartland Louisville
independent person Carl Hawkins they've
been in the west uh Tom Brownstone
Democratic services manager Karen
Hewlett Democratic benefits
questions
hey I'm Robert millward I'm Vice chair
of the trustees at the burden
I'm Warren column I'm the collections
and exhibitions manager at the virgin
I'm chairman of the Board of Trustees uh
to welcome from Judith Gentry a couple
of years ago
hi I'm Sarah Lawrence uh protesting
[Music]
well good afternoon uh thank you for
inviting us to come along to your
committee meeting it's a great
opportunity to meet you face to face
because we often hear it names and
although we meet with some councils we
don't meet with all so it's a great
opportunity to to explain what we do
with the money that you validates
through the service and funding
agreement
not money of course is primarily there
to ensure that your collection The
Collection that was formerly storage's
collection of artworks in the former uh
person of biddeford's gallery is
maintained to the standard you would
hope and expect
and indeed it is
we benefit from that money and we know
that it was reduced because of the
constraints on your budgets and don't
understand that we also are in receipts
of money from Arts Council England
because we are called a national
portfolio organization
and that label was awarded to us because
of the quality of the collections and
Ceramics and in paintings and also the
work that we do to bring National
exhibitions to the Burton
the national exhibitions are of the
highest order that come from well-known
organizations such as the Tate uh the
British I mean British library and
the v a Victorian Albert Museum so these
are As Good As It Gets and they come to
benefit
the funding from Ace
was allocated from 2018 to 2022
through covid ACE decided that they
couldn't get clarity from the government
about ongoing funding so they split a
four-year Grant into a one-year
and three years we applied for the
one-year Grant by
2022-23 and were successful
and we then applied for the 23 to 26
Grant and again we were successful
however
the money that we're going to receive
from our council is going to be the same
2026 as it was in 2018.
so in real terms that's quite a
significant reduction
and of course your service and funding
agreement was reduced somewhat as well
so that puts a bit of pressure on us but
the board is
strong and experienced they come from a
whole variety of walks of life including
Finance Heritage education
the Arts sector through merchandising
and other other facets too
our principal aim is to care for the
collection but along with that comes the
requirement to broaden the community's
horizons about what art is and what it
can do for them
we have outstanding exhibitions and they
receive rave reviews from everybody who
comes into the building
the value of the works we have
particularly the value of the touring
exhibitions is significant it's of the
order of over a million pounds for many
of those natural exhibitions because
they include works of art by famous
British and international artists
in particular people from Cornwall and
Devon but also
works from well-known names like Picasso
Montreal
and many others that you would have
heard of
in order to care for both the touring
exhibitions and our own collection we
have to have an air conditioning system
those works of art had to be stored in a
particular way
that air conditioning system costs
this last year the cost was 30 000 per
hour
I've just heard last week it's going up
to 45
000 per annum
and that is just the first indicative
Uprising we've made here more in April
or next winter
so that puts pressure on us
but
Although our operational costs are
rising
our income is static budgets are tight
but we have the skills to create a
balanced budget
we had a good year in 2122 where we
exceeded expectations because of
lockdown and tourists coming to the area
this current year I think will break
even
so we are still in a stable financial
situation and I expect that to consume
we are the cultural attraction for
Biddeford
not only do we have those collections
but we engage the community
hundreds of school children come in
college students
this morning dead and Recovery Unit was
there in conjunction with national
health to have people on the edge of
society being supported
we have preschool groups come in we have
Outreach through our Burton art box and
have taken that to communities as far as
I'm going to have to ask Lauren to
clarify that but certainly into the more
rural communities in order that they can
see that within their region and at
their probably most local Big Town we
have something to be proud of that's
worthy of a visit
okay
drivers for our work are not only that
set of collections but also a document
that came out on Arts Council called
let's create it's a national document
that
is its intention is to guide museums
galleries theaters and other cultural
organizations
to make sure that they deliver the very
best that they can on half of the money
that's allocated from government through
Arts Council
your interpretation of that document is
this flourishing culture document which
you've approved that came to us a couple
of months ago or so certainly this
ultimately came to us and I'm pleased to
see that whoever was behind the
Creations reports from your team has
made reference to the Burton those
example of good practice within it and
Our intention is to build on that in the
full coming years
that's supposed to be a 500 intro I
don't think it was I'm now going to hand
over to the person who knows in much
more detail about the work that goes on
in the gallery because he's employed
there and he has some slides to show you
to demonstrate some of that activity
thank you very much Tim
um thank you for allowing this
opportunity to speak to you um I have a
selection of slides
um with some things that were really
pleased to provide for toys
um how do I actually just say inside
okay
is that good so if we can go to the next
slide
um somebody became a trust in 2015.
um we have a small dedicated team with
over 50 active volunteers
um those active volunteers are very
important to us and we get engaged with
them on a day-to-day basis
um I'm going to whip through this
because Tim mentions that some of the
things which we do so I don't really
want to support you the same information
but we can look after a collection of
national artworks surrounding some
photography and we continually build on
that collection we also offer a diverse
exhibition program of national local
exhibitions diverse engagement programs
reaching over 4 000 individuals across
the tourist in the last year
we offer a school's engagement program
for primary schools and secondary
schools and we work with up to and over
15 Community groups including women's
Refuge homeless group women's group NHS
Deputy McCain Learners and many more
um next slide please
right my slides have been
disrupted but I will bear with me and
argument so if as far as the visitors
are concerned we reach in the rat in the
average of 200 000 visitors per year
this is the same as major large city
galleries which were extremely um you
know proud to to have those numbers we
usually have around about 15
Expeditions each year local National and
international significant
in high profile Works into the rural
areas as Tim said because of the
infrastructure of the building
nature the work of a high caliber purely
because we can work at the same level as
major organizations are actually working
out at the same time we have an
award-winning contemporary ceramic to
exhibition gallery
two national significance to
surroundings collections the RJ
collection and Christine Hallstead
Correctional Studio Ceramics in 2019 we
acquired an English iron now that's the
photograph by James reverse a collection
number 130 significant vertical ass
capturing rural North Devon and I'm
pleased to say James has is getting the
the attention which he deserves as a
photographer
um we have a museum of bidford offering
ongoing displays with new notice from
the permanent collection and local
history we also offer a tourist
information and we at least engage with
250 people per week with this service
and most important we're free we're free
to all next libraries
so exercise
as Tim mentions of Imagine mentions that
are able to
work at a certain level with exhibitions
um
high profile exhibition Partners include
Museum
the text
the Royal Academy
of stories
Christia Roberts Gallery London British
novel British Council aspects
and the VNA
collection your collection to other
Galleries and museums
[Music]
for education and Learning Resource and
public organizations
for our players from the collection at
the exhibition
next slide is
sorry no problem
s
vulnerable groups locally as Tim
mentioned we work with the NHS trust
partnership and currently offering a
second
[Music]
[Music]
but we also uh well-being and
mindfulness workshops we have created
plant worked off free events and artists
interviews
we also offer who am I really works
work to engage with Burton and has
ongoing sponsorship secures a sold out
Art School supporting home-educated
children in achieving Arts Waters and
qualifications
free workly workshops and activities for
young people the Burton artworks
offering arts and creative activities to
all rural areas
good afternoon series of collaborative
music events
a networking hub for teachers working
alongside the exhibitions and permanent
collections in
2021-22 a total of 20 stores were
engaged with with our exhibitions and
collections
and we offer a mentoring program for
students and volunteers for higher
education and have the opportunity to
work with PhD students no students to
work with us and to our collections
um could we go to the next slide and
slide after that please
so this is a pie chart
um which clarifies
where our money comes from
um
who mentions
we have external funding from
Arts Council and you can see our
fundraising and as you can see in the
green is our earned income and those are
constant challenges which we are faced
with on a day-to-day basis but what I
will say is that we use the collections
your collections and now the birth of a
selection in a way which actually can
live for its work for its living and we
are
ongoing with creating new narratives
from that lecture Reinventing those old
objects in a way which is a contemporary
and more versatile
um
it's a way of engaging in the
Contemporary language and we continue to
do that by commissioning artists to
interpret their work through our objects
thank you for listening to some of the
things which we do
and I've got just very short notes and
conscious of your time so that you have
some assurance that it's not just
sitting and going detailing person we as
Warren said it's looking at how
collections can work and once greater
doing that but we've also been looking
at how we can
um collaborate with that minded with
other Organization for example the uncle
Book Festival how we can possibly do
something together we'll learn awareness
and income we've also been invited on to
the Regeneration board to represent the
Burton and the other communities that
sit around this table uh once a month
is the community but also build
awareness from that we've just been
Greenland for a project to utilize our
art box when it's not as part of the
main programs that Warren's been
speaking about and also the summer
programs we're actually going to be
collaborating with North Devon plus to
study Burton bideford regeneration
entrepreneur partnership where as you
know there are a couple of empty units
which are hard to get hold of the pop-up
shops but together with the support of
the Regeneration board we're going to
look at how we can put pop-ups inside
the art box and join others on the key
so we're trying to do different things
as well as personally it's great for us
to have a presence in closer to the
center of town to offer workshops and
also keep spraying the word about the
power in ours other organizations that
we're working with we're looking at
sponsorship as Warren and Tim mentioned
about some of our events obviously in
respect to the collections that were
part of those plans so we're not
clashing but also looking at how we can
build more Partnerships and see if we
can generate some other opportunities
for awareness and income through the
work that we do daily thank you
and that that's the kind of formal part
of it I don't know if there's anything
we must we'd like to add Rob
not not really but just just to
reiterate that going forward we
um are looking to
diversify our income uh further with
with sponsorship patronage one area
we're looking at is uh legacies
um potentially we've got a a friends
organization which
is not working as well as it would like
it to be so we need to to develop that
um and potentially then uh encourage
those members to include us in their
Wills
um yeah there certainly is will be an
opportunity for sponsorship in the area
and witness the Apple door Book Festival
they they get both
local sponsors and uh well Harlan and
wolf for instance um is one of their
sponsors you know we we don't we
currently we're not really doing that at
the moment and we want to look at that
going forward
um
I suppose you've spoke many times about
admission charges and uh
terrible to think that one day you know
you may have to consider that like many
of the other museums and Galleries at
the moment is that something to consider
at the moment
to help your income it's something that
has been discussed
it's not on the Forefront of our minds
because
foreign
[Music]
the bottom line for me is that we want
to encourage everyone who can to come in
it's a great social space and we know
because we're in there as volunteers and
awful lot I think I've been in nine
times in the last 10 days that we see
how busy it is with people who this is a
really valuable Community Asset
and a lot of those people including the
friends come in very very regularly
there are 300 members of friends
and I have to say as an organization the
friends I think may be the first to
admit it are getting a little tired of
their 20-year service in the friends a
lot of those people are now in their
late 70s early 80s and it needs
rejuvenating so I've spoken with the
chairman of the friends Association just
suggests the ways in which we can do
just that or get some more young blood
into that organization
um so no we haven't decided to go that
way yet
um
We'll Never Say Never but we would
rather encourage as many people as
possible to come in and keep it as you
know a free of charge entry points one
thing we are doing is
um we should have done it before now but
it is introduce uh Todd donations so
we're gonna have a machine specific
floor
giving money on the other credit card
debit card yes instead of having a cash
key
can I say I think also um I think if you
offer the people the opportunity to make
a donation
and it's free to come in we found that
we've made more money through donations
rather than charging or demanding a an
entrance fee what we have found and what
we've seen with other institutions it
cuts the numbers in half completely
because it automatically puts a barrier
in front of people and it we found
because of those studies we find it much
more productive to put more
easier ways for people to make a
donation more interesting donation boxes
is one trick and we found that to be
much more popular
in order to open and make art accessible
to all one of the key things which I
Champion is giving people the
opportunity in a rural area to have a
level of high profile artwork so they
don't necessarily need to go to London
to Liverpool to Manchester to see the
major organized organizations who are
able to deal in high profile artworks
they can come to Budapest and they can
see the same level of artwork which
they're seeing in those major
institutions and they can see for free
hopefully they'll spend in the shop and
they will spend time in the restaurant
where they will spend some more money
but hopefully they will visit two or
three times rather than just once where
they have to pay I think a couple other
things like that there and one is we
made reference to the number of visitors
and we count those through a ticket
machine
person recognition system
it's been
180 to 200 000 people regularly for the
last two or three years
I'm a volunteer at rosemore they get 230
000 a year so we're on a par in Broad
terms with the number of visitors that
is quite something for Biddeford and it
is it makes us the our guest and big
sheep might argue but I'd probably
suggest that it's the largest venue for
visitors in town and surrounding area
and in addition to just being a number
it's it's giving them an experience that
they won't forget
[Music]
um
I think Council and I hope it's not a
question but it's not really a question
it's just a comment really but it's on
that theme I mean I just think it's
absolutely fantastic that it's free and
I know so many people who've got say
half an hour to kill or with their
children or something and then they go
in there and they wouldn't go in there
if they had to pay
um and also there's this element that
you you must find you're fighting about
against a little bit of of it being you
know art museums are being a bit High
ground and the minute you start charging
I think you you if you can avoid it at
all costs that's brilliant because the
minute you start charging it accentuates
that whereas if it's free it just means
it's really interested for everybody and
I take my life
you're right in the sense that you know
there is a Viewpoint from the problem
certainly historically that uh but I
think we've proven with the community
engagement at so many different levels
but actually you know
we can make the successful to everybody
and the perfect example of that is a
year ago
when a member of our team went to the
women's refuge on a weekly basis to try
and get them to engage in some Arts
activity because they were isolated and
they had no cultural experience
after going in for a few weeks she got
them to create some pieces of work
related to an exhibition that was on in
the gallery
they turned them into Christmas cards
that were sold in the game and they sold
out
and then as a follower
that member of the team invited those
ladies to come into the gallery and for
nearly all of them it was their first
ever visit into the museum in a gallery
and they all absolutely loved it and I
think for me that's a perfect example of
the way in which we can engage the
community
another one was this morning from the
debit Recovery Unit there was a group
working up in the Kingsley room upstairs
and a chap came in and he got an annual
route he was saying do you have people
like me in here it was my academicism I
said oh we get all sorts in here he said
well even on once I said well join the
club and he said well where is it and we
talked about because an upper where
certainly has a nice he was late
just a satisfaction basically he had a
nice chat up there and he came down and
had a good time so there are all sorts
of tangents to this but it shows that
we're not being aloof we're not eyebrows
although there are absolutely well let's
see exhibitions we bring that down to
earth and I think the the thing that
Warren was saying about the museum I
don't mind admitting that originally I
wasn't from North Devon my son moved
here before I did he was in South
Monsoon about 10 years ago we started
coming to the gallery here and every
time I came to see my son and his wife I
came over to benefit with them and we
went into energy Park and we went around
the exhibitions
and
for me what I saw 10 years ago in that
upstairs Museum didn't quite engage
it doesn't happen I think Council
Harden's got a question yeah I mean uh
yeah Cafe De Parr is a great asset I can
imagine being right there and uh you
know and Joe I've known every years and
he's a really good Chef uh but uh
basically we've got a lot of emerging
artists in the area I mean my ward is
hard in which you know welcome to Valley
uh Bradley that so we've got um uh a
young artsmith that she's moved down
she's on them here on that and she has
made lots of commissions for likes of
common garden and the Brewers uh gate
and things like that and you know are
you going to be using the emerging
artists that are on the scene now
because we've got double down at the
Valley now have done
um
um as a display actually went very well
so it'd be nice to see some yeah I
couldn't agree more you know and you
know one of the things which we sort of
try and I Champion is is accessible to
all
not just my profile but actually one of
the most important exhibitions which I
value is the skortex fish
um and it's it's about I've always just
regard the person as being layers of an
onion and there are many layers to what
we revise and that comes with the type
of artwork which we deal with we can
deal with the potassos and we can deal
with the baldness but we also can deal
with little Jimmy and these dinosaur
picture and we need to deal with those
in between that and we offer two we
offer a whole range of different
opportunities from artists commissions
which are open artist Commissioners so
they have the opportunity to actually
submit work to those those to those
proposals they have two open exhibitions
in the year where they have an
opportunity to show work and gallery one
and go into and that's through the
Bedford and Western of our society and
through the annual Christmas exhibition
which was on at the moment those agreed
to open to all that's not just members
and it doesn't need to be professional
artists but it can be hobby artists
amateur artists or professional artists
so there is always an opportunity and
I'm always open ears to to help people
you know to grow their own practice and
I think that's one of the things which I
can do personally is actually give
something back with my experience I've
been at the gallery 22 years now and
I've been part of that and the
collection has become very personal and
I've dealt with a lot of artists and it
is it's a way I can actually contribute
and help people grow their practice I
was that little boy that uh you know art
and every exhibition from the school
it's kept me going and I do a bit now
and it's nice and it's uh it you know it
it does give you connection and I very
often go in there and I have a wonder
and uh and then talking to see Joe it's
it's just it's nice to just touch base
and see what is happening and uh yeah
and there's the cross coloring as well
we we do exhibit or sell a lot of
artists work there and and we turn it
over yes and that's you know a variety
of
styles of genre and materials are used
in there and the other thing is that we
always keep an eye on emergency artists
and opportunities so an example of that
is through the project that's Easter
Wars the remorse development
friends knows the gallery comes to some
of our private views
um and engages with us about opportunity
a lot of those opportunities that
know knowledge of what the details are
but people when that comes to permission
the plan is that through US artists will
be engaged to create real-time games for
an entrance and to do various other
pieces in Ceramics and metal work and in
other mediums in order to provide other
opportunities another income for high
quality local buses so it's always on
the radar but it's not always possible
because of the size of the building to
do as much as we would like too and that
that is
she caught my eye on me yeah
um
[Music]
oh I'm just a boy
I remember saying that we had a survey
see what priorities our customers right
there have and it was uh it was been
shocking to me actually because most
people were more concerned about their
bin backs being connected and they were
about art and culture which actually
came down
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
to say too much so I'll be quiet but
there you know follow up on Pitch the
rich um because it's very true
um interesting and that I've got a ward
that it was from just a half a mile here
for a bit of a town at all but I go all
the way to Brad with him but I take the
time asking you know will we get a
direct debates about funding or the
other bits and pieces I'm always amazed
when I go on the other outer edges of my
wart which is now 10 miles and how
valuable the Burton is been to people
that's not just in bittyford and it's
really surprised me actually
um because I'm not an artist by it I
couldn't even pay the war well talk
about any of the pictures I mean that's
what I I come from but they say there's
an artist and everyone but I'm not sure
that it applies to me from one situation
so I congratulate in the work you've
done that's been particularly prominent
since you've had you know you guys have
been in control I think since the 2016
or 2017 I think you you've had the the
contract and I'm also a little bit
impressed okay that I think under the
first five years it costs targets about
109 um
about the funding bits and pieces I've
been to see a graph of there and this
five years since
2020
one I think last year if you've got five
years again but you don't I think it's
1470s
under 32 but it was
interested
I mean on hearing that there were two
things I did when I became share one was
to make sure because we were down to
four trustees first thing was to make
sure we got them through
because four people can't do everything
so we built it up to maximum which is
nothing since then one person has left
or in 38
um
and the second thing was to talk with
Rob who who was relatively new who sits
on person Enterprises personal
Enterprises is the commercial Wing yeah
that sits alongside us which is a
requirement of the law because otherwise
we couldn't touch other status so uh I
said to Robin the others Sarah's on that
as well as I think Sarah was on before
though
um we're getting sequence but basically
we're going to have to make some more
money because if Torres can't afford to
give us as much as in the past we've got
to find a way of saying
now in that first year there
I think there were a lot of questions
raised by you because you deal in that
marketing and Merchandising in the Arts
work wasn't had to address your career
but that led down to people like Sarah
and Kate in the in the team in the shop
and craft battery so
what else could we put on display here
that will sell
but of course there's a balancing act
because you can either have very
expensive items in the craft gallery and
I saw a picture this morning at 2 300
and something
and so a lot of those are making some
income or you can have lots of tax in
the shop and get lots of tea because to
come along and buy their 50p pencil
eraser and make you know no proper
Disorder so it's all about us but that's
where the skills and equity and suppose
in that world we could
um and I have to say the team that are
running it they run it with love they'll
go to the trade shows they'll look at
their message they'll look at they're
obviously they're looking at the bottom
line but they're even taken into the
situation who's coming through and what
they might like and what they're
reacting to so there is a huge good of
cesarea who runs that and adds a
colleague saying it's been a long time
now yeah absolutely it runs out with
passion and even looking at
sustainability as well you know Sarah
didn't wait to be spoken to about that
one she just actually makes it so much
more than well all of us that do a great
job yeah on the uh your territorial side
as well Warren and his team
and and the Outreach works yeah it's a
it's a great thing in terms of the
sustainability approach we're
environmentally conscious so we're
trying to play our part
and some of that's been very successful
so the commercial side of things the
main plastic free a good couple of years
ago which is great
having said that we're learning fuel
what happened before because we have to
keep your collection in good order and
that is a real challenge you know
today's
difficult times
um
our main decision-making committee
agreed the package I think quite
substantially but there was opposition
from the rest of the council and it got
according to to our internal robberies
currently interesting the debate it was
hard at the time
um about the action funding going
forward
um the pictures change in the local
government because funding is getting
quite a level like like all of us we've
got pressures coming all our our funding
situation are you going to do anything
that's going to encourage
I explained to what will be a new
Council from next may but what you do so
just to say you will have a new Castle
and there is one or two who we are for a
good reason and they'll have stronger
reasons next time what are you going to
do to put in place to
justify because you do a lot at the
present moment and I do you get all your
invitations and you should break stuff
down there and I particularly enjoyed
I'm a form of my background and
rebellious was fantastic I have to
congratulate you on that I have my phone
I I went there four or five times to see
if that situation but I'm saying what
and just to think for the future there
might be more people out there who are
worried about the level of cultural tax
we won't have to set next next year and
uh
um there's going to be huge questions on
on budgets Etc are you aware that there
was a bit of negative Edition but there
was concern about the amount of coming
from tolerance without going into
Central Jersey from this very
professional about it she explained that
the being challenged and that was it's
right but there should be a challenge
there but at the same time
um you know there was a recognition that
the world
in which we live at the moment is one in
which the public burst is typed and we
understand that do we have a strategy to
counterbalances not really I'm honest
but we well I can say is we are having
increasingly increasing conversations
about the notion of sponsorship and
other ways of bringing money in
um there's no magic want because you
know only too well
at the bottom line for us is that we
want to deliver on behalf of our
community we live here and we you know
we we value storage it was interesting
seeing your sign over the desk in the
entrance or say something in the
entrance set to where the officers at
Riverside
storage a great place to work live and
something else I heard from my wife this
week that toriage is the happiest place
in Britain in which to live yeah
so do we have a plan not yet but I
suppose the answer is if the new
councilors who are elected
don't value Burton as much as is
currently the case they will have to
come up with a plan the challenge is
that
we're not magicians and we will do our
very best on your behalf
um
both the fund and everything else I
think the greatest uh
um the argument but debating you must be
having is that
um so many people visit people are not
going it's free and you know as
counselors we are mindful of that object
and everything else
but sometimes it's not all about your
money you know it's people's lives and
only limit and um you know if you're
doing something for somebody who's
they're improving their lives because
they're committed a partner all right
then that is above money isn't it way
above money so if you've got all those
thousands of people coming to the art
yeah I mean that must mean something in
monetary charges and in terms of mental
health yeah so there's public at large
yeah it's it's crucial I think yeah it's
it stops isolation you see a lot of
single owned people
but you know when you see people who are
in the races who've lost their Partners
um they've got their friends but they
always used to go in and say hi
there they still go in and they meet
other people like that you know in terms
of the good it does it's phenomenal
um
yes at this time we're going through
these times though of hardship and uh it
was constantly living going up the
burden is a really great thing people
can go there for free
and have some sort of entertainment and
you know
um it's getting good A bit of walking
and you know sometimes it's like
libraries it's just like that when times
are hard you do very well because he
used to be very well as well because
they can go into feet and you know it's
something I am going to spend out lots
of money coming to the park or something
like that and another point I would make
is um put foreign new councilors just
remind them that on the purely financial
side that if if it was to go back to TDC
then
that's a valid argument to me yeah thank
you chair um you mentioned about energy
costs I mean the huge Council coming up
next year the council will be looking to
see what you're doing to to offset these
energy costs and have you looked at all
the options and energy energy saving
devices solar panels all those sort of
things yes so you've got a very strong
board well one of the members used to
run Demon's Property Services and
um he has he's now I'm not sure what I'm
saying that he's he's left Devon
property to build a Southwest water
um in a senior managerial role
he has connections and has been
exploring conversations
members of the storage team about energy
saving
uh opportunities
first thing to say on that is that we
are still in the time scheme that you
have I think via Kent is that right
am I mistaken with that and I don't know
yeah
um but we are outside digital scheme
we probably feel because it's safer to
stay in with your scheme than it is to
go out isolated and be bitten off by the
big boys
we've looked at solar energy until about
two and a half weeks ago we heard
through Al who's who's this child who is
on the board but there he thought was
going to be a 25 000 pound grams for the
installation of solar energy through
some scheme that one of your team had
identified
and the question he put to me was could
we match funded because that will make a
big difference I said well I haven't a
clue because you don't know if you don't
try
the next time I spoke with him well I'd
heard that the grants had gone now I
don't know if that's true or not
um
so I don't know where that came from I
don't know the detail all I know is that
if anybody can get some more options
here World
um I think we do work with such as
the boiler scheme etc etc do such things
and the other thing was cavity Park and
we've had a walking group the college
walk and talk walking for health we meet
in the park on a Wednesday why did all
the vendors are coming to the into the
cafe afterwards and it's the way of
carrying encouraging them to go in and
have a good look around somebody been
walking for years have never actually
gone into
the Museum Part or the gallery when
displays are on well that's a
conversation we've been paying
percentage of Sarah
because we know we get people from you
know as we've said from South Somerset
North Cornwall mid to heaven and
elsewhere coming in
um
and yet there are people in the town
who've never said to us in the gallery
and that just you know any kind of
surprises us but then we think we'll
have to how can we improve the site
boasting and we've tried
um I last raised that as a presentation
I think in this room
um to be different Council back in July
August
um we came along so I spoke Artemis with
one of your team who's a county
councilor
consuming
yeah
because all that debris from the London
Plains blown straight inside the
building
and the second was about improving
signage now she tried her best and she
gave me various contacts which I
followed up but it's basically going in
a kind of Circle of eight I figure of
eight where we get across from
participation and essentially it seems
there isn't enough money to get the
trees full of it
um because it's highways
um highways have also the type of
budgets and that's for signage even the
signposts we talked about
um opposites the the London office
apparently it's full and we can't
consider putting anything else obviously
perks down here so we that's why we've
got these flags up on the front of them
gallery to try to trap those people and
get dropped off in the summer on buses
so not just walk straight up the key and
come into town but to actually realize
that as you go and have a very nice time
for an hour you know I wanted to go and
we have also looked at again so we're
not waiting for people to find that and
the team will obviously doing their own
language program and also the summer
programs in the in Parks which is
amazing I do love the silent display but
also we have been investigating trying
to look at empty units how we can put
art in there engaging some of the school
projects and have their artwork in there
so that as people will buy they can feel
proud that they can part of it you know
part of an exhibition so we have
exploring some other projects in return
I want to bring VR into the town even
um one lovely estate agent we might have
had might possibly give us a unit for
our incoming Lego exhibition which we'll
see in a yellow yellow brick road run
through so we're trying to engage and
bring out into the town so it's
accessible but you know we like a
challenge and that's why the art box and
possibly we get that space since that's
fantastic
well there's enough empty shops on Billy
for it to either put a picture in about
35 minutes I should think
I had conversations about seven to three
years ago the challenge I think is uh
sometimes
issues with landlords who don't want
some kind of things and it gets
complicated
and then the other night is that well no
we have the ones that lasted packs in
the gallery of the museum we don't
necessarily have the rights no so that's
another issue because
for example owns quite a lot of the
rights although the collection is in
here and that's one of those tensions
that will never well
because this gentleman here while under
your collection manager he left school
and joined the birds he's been there
forever yeah
just another side topic interesting new
members of visitors 230 000 I think he
said at Hillsborough yes
um
I always think Real Sports got a huge
Advantage because you pay whatever it is
your membership I mean my wife's a
member and I get a free ticket on the
back of that so I'm very grateful to my
wife
um
and I'm amazed how often at different
times of the year
store actually as well
um and I told it in Torres we have the
highest percentage of day visitors of
any District in Denver because people
who are soakedown for the holiday and
then come up to Rose Lord because they
belong to rhs Wesley or rhs
and come up to the area I just wondered
if you could one have a membership card
where you yeah I mean if you've actually
said you're going to pay 10 pounds to be
a member foreign
[Music]
but what do I get for that because I'm
going to be going into that Gallery
anyway
but it's a way of doing it now the
principally remembers
well I've discovered in the last week
that not all paying 40 pounds membership
fees because some joined 20 years ago
and their standing orders haven't been
amended so they're paying whatever it
was collecting Isabella schedule we need
something about that and that's part of
the conversation like
the point of view of uh not to I mean
certain friends you may be paying 50
pence a year though yeah
um but what I was interested it provides
you know people belong to something and
is this for long that that makes you
think I would like to join that and I
just wondered whether your approaches of
other galleries you're working with in
Ace and all the rest whether there's
strength in there and belong to
something that says this Gallery is
Bristol and this one is the Dives and
this wasn't
certain conversations yes what what do
get for the membership for 40 pounds
it's the entitlement to come along to
the private view Expressions which
launch every single exhibition so every
time Warren comes to do exhibition there
is a private view yeah right and so
there was a glass of wine and they get a
glass of wine so if there are six
events well they come to the mall it
seems the last things
my wife and I I don't attendantly
[Music]
a couple of classes
but you know there is that sense of uh
almost like a group Club almost you know
the sense that they are contributing and
of course if they all did pay
this is where my muscle I'll ask the
accountant here if they all did pain or
300 people paid 40 quid that's
right yeah
um sorry one of the things that Springs
to mind as soon as you have those 300
members to be reported like running what
I would call a 300 club or a 400 Club
where you get something in
a benefit for being there and I want to
run a couple myself
I think you could make
most probably even if they pay two
pounds each a month for 600 Quid
first prize 300. if I could say with
friends of organization
Etc foundation of the trust yeah so it's
independent and I think the friends have
come we were talking about this actually
requires coming in here because
obviously in the time we're trying to
make the friends organization has
changed quite dramatically in the last
20 years because of people's invest
people's status people's age and all
those different other different factors
now that's not necessarily there anymore
for the friends but I mean for a turning
point where they need some sort of help
in the direction which is going to
more often from this 300 but in order to
do this new modernization and the idea
is I think going forward if we can do
this in-house then obviously we can take
control of this and then obviously that
would benefit what you're saying based
communicate sense and then you can offer
something in the vision for being a
manager at the moment we don't control
that that's up to the they are in
control of their own organization and
it's it'd be rude for me to input or
suggest something which they would do
even know that we know when they could
be doing this and I think there is going
to be a point where actually they're
going to have no choice but actually to
consider allowing some help in order to
exist
we've got as far as to investigate the
legality of that you know the financial
indications of that because they have
some assets and consequently they manage
their funds and when they get around
they're able to then give us a grant for
a particular piece of work so there is a
trip that an income comes out there and
if we took it in-house we met with the
childhood accountants in our last board
meeting a couple of weeks ago and he's
explained that actually their assets
could come alongside the palace but they
would be in restricted funds so they
wouldn't be put into our mail signal but
they would be there for specific
purposes and if we had a
a project or if there was another
photographer like the villius that we
wanted to say Well we'd love to have
another 10 inches a different
photographer or another five paintings
from somebody locally that was on repeat
we might be able to buy those in that
little connections that's where those
restricted ones would come in that's the
sort of thing that we that we are
looking at a reorganization potentially
uh but we obviously need to do that in
consultation with them and as you say
there are other opportunities to to
benefit you know long-serving members
and so on
and patronage as well again ultimately
we could have some um you know their
names on the board yeah
I'm going to be 70 this year and I'm
probably the youngest member of the
friends so yeah
they need to find a way
but they don't know how
I'm not sure we know now but I'm sure
together we can find a way of
rejuvenating the friends so that we have
young friends contraction of people from
petrock who are still studying out there
and there aren't many up there so and
captions students leaving you know at
school are those still you know
teenagers and give them a young friends
membership opportunities might of course
nothing but when they get to 18 it might
cost them apply for them when they leave
University it might cost them 10 and
then when they get to addict so the they
feel that they're part of the burden so
there are schemes like that which
started to talk about we haven't gone
we haven't
written down they're just kind of
starter conversations but we are having
them I think um one thing that's quite
important that we haven't really touched
on is the accessibility it doesn't
matter whether your own Mobility Scooter
or so open plate like that in there he's
93 and a half and um he will he can go
around on his Mobility Scooter I'll do
cringe sometimes
yeah
but then he likes to come back through
the shop and I know he's going to buy
something for mum or himself or you know
another sibling or something and it is
just an experience that he can't have
access to
anywhere else you know he's restricted
to someone at Morrisons
um anybody else got any question for the
team
um
um we've just been to the accessibility
I know there's a little incline down to
the door and this time of year and I see
older make sure you've got some leaves
on there
um is there any risk at all uh what
there is a risk there
um yes we are aware of that as you can
notice there is a small patch of slaps
there which is the only area which gets
a little bit moldy
um we just recently put some mold spray
on it which obviously and we're keeping
an eye on it so we're constantly look
around for somebody who's sweeping up
their leaves weekly and he's when he
walks past it and if it needs to end
we'll do it straight away so it's been
much washed last week but it's been
storage is responsible for the building
yeah
um would you benefit from an operation
of anything to make that access easier
about
attaching ability
in its broader sense and I know that
going back to someone
five six years conversations about
libraries and libraries but
the long-term ambition would be to
expand that would be our Dream to find a
way of expanding because you know
storage is showing a problem
the team has 11 members and they have
three desks that's a problem
and we're at saturation Point within the
building so are you talking about the
organic expanding in that building or
are you thinking about the burden at
times or the burden that those will be
yeah it could be either well
either or or
both I mean I know going back when there
was possibility of getting some
government funding for
regeneration in town with the
the project that we weren't successful
in uh there was a possibility that the
burden might have a presence there in
some form maybe maybe
explored uh but we were interested if
there was an opportunity and that
interest remains there but it's subject
to capacity because we have a small
scene when we have a restricted budget
you know things changed at the time so
if in 10 years time
the country was in a better state so
there was more money
so we were facelift and expand in order
to accommodate our artifacts better and
provide a better space for visitors
[Music]
okay I don't think there are any further
questions we will just change your law
brief meeting thank you very much for
having your welcome this will take about
three minutes so that's it very long
thank you for that it was really
important
I do apologize for being late
[Music]
yeah
I remember the
presentation yeah I think it's just you
know sometimes it's more engaging for us
to look at the person who's talking
anyway yeah
um look at a screen so
um moving on to item number nine which
is consideration of the board's plan
um obviously become April May who knows
if I'll be sat here or not and what we
are still considering the forward plan
further on and um we have
[Music]
um
toys
um
so you know they're going to be in a
better place and have more information
if you'd like to cancel Alexander
[Music]
play areas Etc but I just wondered back
to Torres now as a board that is I don't
understand
from 1610 it's not a whole world so it
is considered as a separate entity
in its own that's why that's question
thank you chairman
um
[Music]
into external
um
prepare Trust on in March which I think
it said Council Pennington to be on full
form if I were here
um
so we've not gone to that and then
that's it that's for me thank you
a little time